[Music]
6 10 on your Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy I think Junior traffic
buddies may know the answer to this one
but I think some folks are still curious
the viewer wants to know why some school
zone flashing lights are flashing even
when there's no school
Bert writes all around town I see those
25 mile an hour wind flashing lights in
the mornings and afternoons can't they
be turned off when school's out can
police still ticket drivers violating
the speeds even when there's no school
Lambert you're not the only one
wondering so I'm happy to help the
lights aren't on at every campus but the
ones that are on we're keeping kids safe
during a couple of weeks of summer
classes and the others are still being
used because some campuses serve meals
for the students meaning youngsters
hopefully using crosswalks and drivers
slowing down because to answer your
other question yeah violators are
subject to citation
Bert thanks for writing it's always good
to keep an eye out for kids around
schools and guess what kids hey classes
do start again just over a month
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone you can join the driving
you crazy conversation we are traffic 8
at 8newsnow.com